gardening is a rewarding hobby that
connects you with nature start by
determining your goals do you want
vegetables herbs or flowers assess your
space for sunlight soil quality and
layout choose plants that suit your
climate and are easy to grow like
tomatoes basil or marigolds gather
essential tools a garden Trel hand Fork
pruners gloves and a watering can clear
your garden area of weeds and debris
loosen the soil and add organic matter
like compost decide on inground beds
raised beds or containers based on your
space and needs decide whether to start
from seeds or seedlings seeds are
cost-effective but require more care
seedlings offer convenience for seeds
follow packet instructions for depth and
spacing for seedlings Harden them off
before transplanting water gently and
provide optimal conditions for growth
water consistently preferably in the
morning or late afternoon use mulch to
retain moisture and suppress weeds
fertilize with Organic options like
compost or fish Emulsion prune regularly
to encourage growth and manage pests
with natural remedies like neem oil or
beneficial insects harvest vegetables
and herbs when they reach the desired
size cut flowers in the morning for
freshness hey everyone if you enjoyed
this video make sure to hit that like
button and subscribe to our channel for
more awesome content don't forget to
click the Bell icon so you never miss an
update thanks for watching and see you
next time